according to some the devil is hard at
work across America Reverend Bob Larson
is on a mission to drive him out
I believe demonic activity today is more
prevalent than ever it's just the
zeitgeist the time in which we live and
demons like this time Jesus crazy go
down for Jeanette mana those demons are
all too real tormented for years by
depression Jeanette is turned to
spiritual help from the exorcists of Bob
Larson's church as the exorcism begins
she experiences a vision of Romans
burning down her house the Romans came
in Center houses on fire the vision
suddenly becomes terrifying this way
exorcists believe demon possession can
reside in a blood line passing through
multiple Drake the crew write the curse
now with each passing minute
Jeanette's behavior changes erratically
from distraught to calm to hysterical
laughter then pure terror meme of Jesus
Christ what is your name and after 40
grueling minutes loser Nelson go now
just will it to go Jeanette he has to go
looser now tell us once college Annette
exorcists believe that yawning and
belching are signs that a dealer is
leaving the body if you goes make sure
now
thank you Jesus Jeanette's ordeal
appears to be over the religious
tradition itself creates the condition
of demonic possession fortunately it
also provides the cure you're doing
great great there is an absolute God
there is a devil we're involved in a
cosmic battle the Bible has the answer
to all these problems but suddenly color
break the kernel a second demon finds
its boys no the exorcists gold the
demons releasing its grip on Jeannette
her screaming is both cathartic and
symbolic as she fights to expel the hurt
and torment she has suffered throughout
her adult life let her go if you return
no more than an hour into her exorcism
Janette is physically ill looser now in
Jesus man Exorcist believe that vomiting
is another sign that demon is leaving
the body
Janette is both physically and
emotionally exhausted was a tough one
he's a big one you oh my god do you
summoned it I literally felt it come out
of somewhere yeah though some may be
skeptical about exorcisms for Jeannette
there is no doubt when they call it the
demon
it doesn't enter in me it's already a
part of me it's a part of my soul so
they're calling up something that's
already there but I know once they cast
it out and it's gone and it's never
coming back